my name is mark util I'm going to talk
about the topic which is called from
data to knowledge and analyze data and
we'll see how much information we can
extract from that data so it'll be
personal fitness trackers data that
measure temperature humidity and things
like that in your house electricity
consumption and so on and we'll try to
deduce some things and make some models
of what we can learn from that
really happy to to be able to speak it's
my first time at one of these
conferences here and it's just great
that I can talk a little bit about what
I've been doing this is just a tiny
little bit of one project that we're
doing and we've been using extensively
for many things the Wolfram language
unfortunately I'm not actually going to
be able to go into the details of
everything I just want to give you a
main idea of what I've been up to so
there are a couple of files I can't
actually easily make publicly available
because there might be patient data and
things like that too but yes the QR code
so if you want to just contact me
there's the email address as well we put
some form of the talk online later and
also we'll give a special thanks to my
co-author heroes Beyonce is in the
second row over there
he works quite a lot with the Wolfram
language tool and he also managed to get
the money for us to come here so that's
great also he's an expert very much on
data analysis so if there any complaints
about anything you see just take this QR
code which is his email address and he'd
certainly be able to help you okay one
of the things I like about the Wolfram
language is well my job is basically
applied mathematicians so I like
modeling things I like to get data look
at the data model things I teach that to
students and we worked with industrial
partners with courts and other things to
just make mathematics realistic and
interesting for all of these areas so my
my basic my hobby is listening to
people's problems and then trying to
make a mathematical induce Mathematica
to move that forward now one of the
things one of the common complaints is
that when you do mathematical modeling
applied mathematics that is this kind of
thing that you see a cow and you say
well in order to be able to do anything
with it we probably have to assume that
it is a sphere so because spheres are
nice and easy to calculate with
mathematically but I think that
Mathematica gives us this unique
possibility to
do things more realistically and for
example if we teach also if you
collaborate with people it's just nice
if you can make things a tiny little bit
more realistic so there are lots of
examples how we would do that so for
example in lectures in what we do is
when we look at heat equations partial
differential equations or so instead of
just calculating that on on a square or
something like that we would actually
take a 3d object we would usually scan
that even though this is just an example
file from from Mathematica itself then
you solve the partial differential
equations on that particular surface and
then you can use something like a heat
camera and show the students and the
people okay this this is actually how it
looks like is our motor good enough how
do we have to modify things like that so
that's one of the things that I like
because you've got all these algorithms
at your hand you don't have to always
program everything in the first instance
we can make very simple models more
complicated so this is a very very
simple si R model you can get a discrete
version of it this is actually a
discrete version these are the equations
that will probably make that a bit
larger or not and you can you can
simulate that and you can actually have
sliders and the students see that that's
all good but then it's they're a very
simple world school or undergraduate
example so what you can do and what I
what we try to do in the classes I teach
is you take additional data for example
data about all the airports in the world
and you can take all these airports and
you get so this is semantic import you
get already the countries and you get
the coordinates and the short versions
of the airport names and things like
that and then you can't find a network
and you can actually say let's assume
that they link populations and let's
look at these populations and see how
diseases can be spread using for example
the network of all the flights in the
world then you can add information about
the health systems of the countries make
nearly little sub models of how you
think the life expectancy depends or
helps to predict perhaps the recovery
rate from such a disease and things like
that so we can make models we can
experiment with them very easy
we can then take the data from the
countries here are different countries
and we actually can look at infection
rates and recovery rates for these
particular countries and you see here
for example Green it's pretty good
because the population density is very
low so it's it's relatively unlikely
that you meet anyone and get infected
and you can make these videos and
animations and see how this would spread
oh dear this is not okay okay so making
the models that tiny little bit more
realistic and very often that is based
on using appropriate data for it now I
think that one of the things when you
analyze data and work with people is
that you want to tell stories with the
data so this here for example is the
temperature global temperature from
January to December for different years
and there's the year and you see this is
the temperatures over the months in the
years and then the time goes up and you
see if you're kind of drowning in these
lines it goes up and up and up and that
explains a little bit how the global
temperature works so how it might change
or might not change you can do of course
then all sorts of statistics on that and
try to explore that with the students
what type of visualizations can we use
to tell this story questions like those
so the project I would like to talk
about today is rather different and
that's one of the projects we do with
industrial partners where we started out
with industrial partners at least and
the idea is that if you have certain
diseases like dementia or epileptic
seizures or something like that there
might be ways to help you but only if
the disease is recognized quite early on
and if you know exactly what triggers it
and things like that
so suppose mmm you are developing
dementia and they develop drugs to help
you but basically you get a form and you
have to fill it in with your doctor and
they show you image of a pencil and they
ask what is it and if you don't know
what a pencil is then they say well this
is bad
and you get medication but that's late
because your brain is already quite
damaged so the questions it's got
something like this called
cognitive reserve so for a while your
brain can actually mask the fact that
that it loses power so all the things we
can try to do is we can try to use
everyday devices like fitbit's Apple
watches Xbox connects mobile phones
things like that and we can try to
figure out whether very early on we can
detect any kind of change in pattern
changing behavior an easy example just I
mean it's more complicated than that but
easy example would be suppose we monitor
your mobile phone and we know exactly
where and how you walk and we see over a
year that it takes you longer and longer
to find you car when you are at the
supermarket at the mall and you want to
go back to the car it takes longer and
longer at the same time we notice that
when you write emails your vocabulary
changes at the same time we notice that
your movement pattern changes and so on
and so on in combination we might be
able to say well something is coming up
here go and talk to your GP and with all
the data we might be able to actually
treat you early on so one of the things
that is important to do and for which
the Wolfram language is really really
really appropriate is collecting lots
and lots of data and combining the data
to make decisions and to to see patterns
so this is a very simple thing I will
make this obviously available for
everyone so there is a little device
this is the cylinder here it's called
netatmo lots of people have that I mean
if you look over the United States you
will see that in nearly every other
Street or so people will have such a
device if it will fit under you can have
at home one outside one inside and it
measures things like temperature
humidity air pressure noise levels
pollution levels stuff like that co2
levels in the house for example the
outside data is made available to the
general public the inn can be made
available to the general public the
inside data not but you can access it so
we learned lots of things but I'll co2
levels first of all it's quite amazing
what you can learn about this you can
learn how many people are in your house
just based on the co2 levels because you
see that the changes depend on how many
people there are you can see that when
people get sick in their rooms the co2
levels will change often so we can
combine that data we can actually write
a little API so they've got an online
our access point to the data
and the little things I do that here
with a little shade script it's really
simple
the only thing what I do that is because
I don't want to show you my password in
plain text so it's really easy to do and
basically the trick is here generates an
access token to the data I what I do
then let me see where I've got internet
yes I do so this is basically the entire
request and if you've got your access
token already which you can get from
their website and you just paste it in
there and this particular bit here asked
for the temperature on many available
stations in Europe a disc in this case
and you see all these points correspond
to a station and the measurements are no
other than five minutes so this is the
actual time now we use that for example
when there was a solar eclipse to just
check the temperature drop in different
places in Europe and things like that
and it runs pretty quick now I can also
do that obviously with the data in my
house this is the quest that's my
station data and if I hit enter I get a
little let it set of icons here and it's
difficult to read perhaps let me see
where I can increase some of these so
you would see there's an air pressure of
996 and you've got noise levels that
there shouldn't be anyone at home so
this is pretty pretty low noise levels
you've got the temperature the co2
levels and so on and I can obviously put
that in a shell your task or something
and get this data on a very regular
basis and can actually follow that up
over over longer periods of time so here
for example the data this is temperature
data and that's inside obviously
everdene is never that warm so this must
be inside and you see there is a pattern
a weekly pattern sometimes it gets lower
you see the houses are not very good
very well insulated either but you've
got these patterns you can start to try
to understand what this stuff for
example is very easy to write with
students a little program to heat your
house optimally based on these kind of
things these are co2 patterns in my
office that's my office and you see I've
got usually five working days sometimes
I come in on the weekends tool
so I don't only learn how much co2 I use
I can see how many people I'm my office
if I look carefully enough and I can
also just detect when I am in my office
the thing is that these data sets are
usually not very good there's missing
data they're all kind of things that can
go wrong the thing is I use various
devices like my mobile phone install a
little IFTTT kind of thing on it a
little program that measures when I'm in
the office and additionally to the data
I get data when my GPS location of my
phone is closer close by in my office
and again you would see that some
weekends on there but not really often
and some days I actually come in and out
of the office quite frequently and
things like that and actually it makes
an automatic kind of schedule of what I
do
additionally I have noise level datas
noise level data so again quite similar
the data contains similar information
and by cohn by combining all of this I
learn a lot about my patterns and the
offers in other things your mobile phone
I'll show that in a moment has about 20
senses so we wrote a little program that
we can access all the data and stream it
to a server if you want so this is just
like a GPS data from from a phone I
think this is the iPhone data and you
see I just go for a walk and you see in
colors the different speeds I walk
around and things like that that's
that's on the compass you can also have
devices like this that's what Rakeem oh
it's a little device that measures the
GPS position and all countries in the
world just uses the telephone network
and uploads the data to a server so that
in intervals of about a minute or so I
always know where people are it also has
a little SOS button so if I've got a
problem I impressed that and asked the
patient for example they need heip how
to do this of course I've got data like
movement data so cell aroma to data of
my mobile phones I see if I change my
walking pattern at one point they're at
about 300 I can see for example
Parkinson's if people start moving in a
different way it's a particular patron
for Parkinson patients movement so I can
detect that early on and of course this
data is not always good here's an
interesting set to see just what what we
have to deal with this is heart rate
data basically I hoped it was measured
with my ever watch
and you see at the beginning up to our
here a kind of different pattern and
that's because I had the first every
watch and then got the second one and
they actually measure differently so
that's that change there's another thing
so if I look at the average heart rate a
little bit averaged over time it goes up
then we've got this horrible dip and it
dips here so I thought I'd going to die
but actually what turns out I got an
additional beddit that's the sense of
you put in your bed and it measures your
odd right so I basically when I'm at
home I can tell you for every night
exactly when my heartbeat sound every
single heartbeat now the thing is that I
didn't have that device that first and
at night your heart rate is usually
lower than during the daytime so the
moment I switched it on I got these
patterns here which are night patterns
and that meant that my heart be dropped
down the problem is that the first
minute I had broke afterwards so there
was a time again when I didn't have it
and then I got the second version of it
and now it works again so we have to
deal with these kind of things that's
difficult it's difficult to see what
happens in people's life I've got eons
data here as well and I can't oh yeah I
shouldn't have disclosed that okay
anyway so he had the first ever watch
and he got the second neighborhood watch
it in the minute he was on a cruise and
there was no you didn't have his watch
with him so there is a gap over there
his heart rate painting is much heavier
than mine's okay there we go
so long-term measurements no problem the
people wouldn't have to care about these
devices just basically what you do every
day there is no change of lifestyle
required or anything like that we do
something with other devices like here
the Xbox so that's an Xbox Kinect we
hacked it a little bit and the Xbox
Kinect for the games they measure how
you're positioned in space how you move
so we get all the data about your
position in space we also get facial
information like whether you are happy
or not we get your pipes rate and we get
all sorts of things a couple of these X
boxes in your house and we know exactly
how you move and if these movement for
example if you shake with your arm
because you've got Parkinson's we see
that too of course so these are 3d
images that's playing tennis you can
actually use that to see whether your
movement is very consistent or whether
there are deviations and this thing is
made with an Xbox and a little bit of
code in a couple of hours in the
afternoon and you can you can actually
look and
and try to understand your movements its
of course it's fully 3d if you've got a
couple of these senses at home you can
distinguish between different people you
can see how they move where they sit
there's a nice post about goldfish in a
in a fish tank on the world from
community somewhere on the block
and you see where the fish are in in the
fish tank now with this you can see
where the people are at home where they
sit how they sit where they do anything
else and also of course you can manage
monitor whether for example an elderly
person falls to the ground doesn't get
up so this thing can automatically send
you an e-mail or a text message or
whatever you want if your grandfather
ever fell to the ground so that's really
easy an Xbox Kinect just to let you know
about it's two hours generates about
half a terabyte to a terabyte worth of
data now we let that run with patience
for a year then we've got a hundred two
hundred patients so you can imagine what
type of data we have to deal with and
that's just one device here's another
thing it's it's called effigy it's long
code I post the code of course again a
similar thing you've got a little device
that you wrap around the cable the
electricity cable that comes into your
house and it basically by induction
measures how much electricity you're
consuming at that point in time there is
a access code again my password I didn't
really want to put it plain text here on
the screen it hopefully is on my on my
desktop so I can download the data for a
week it's quite fast that's the data for
a week there are two peaks one in the
morning one in the afternoon my wife's
working my daughter gets out so that's
basically in the morning when we make
breakfast and in the evening when we go
home you will see that the times are not
actually really matching if you look
closely and that's because now to place
that in u.s. time and we actually live
with UK time so that is a little shift
here which is the time zones I can look
into details because these data are can
be measured every five minutes or even
every minute if I want so this is just
today and this is like I mean this is
just downloaded now so this is what's
happened oh god no what's wrong with you
so let's go back here
so just look I downloaded it just before
we started this talk here so you can see
this and you see there is the I I
suppose because there's six hours
difference so there's six hours before
that will be the evening data that'll be
the morning data and actually we trained
a little neural network because every
single device at your house will make a
particular fingerprint on this so for
example these kind of things go up go
down go up go down that's my fridge okay
every device device does that so with
this I can tell you here you put the tea
kettle on here you cooked here did they
see you did that so they get a complete
without anyone needing to log anything
so it's just from that one measurement
we can do this this is my our telephone
app so we're the student Protea alright
of student programming a little
telephone app you can download it from
the this is the one for for Android you
can download it and can say what your
phone is supposed to measure you can
stream that either to serve or you save
that directory on your phone you get
movement patterns this is me driving
home from university home and actually I
found one where I didn't speed so 70
miles is fine in the UK so took my why
but yeah happens so you see how fast I
go you see how I celebrate you see the
height I have to drive over a mountain
over there which is quite true then
interesting question would be can I
detect from just for high profile from
where to where I've driven so taking the
road network and things like that it's a
nice game really so that's type of
typical data I get from the phone
latitude longitude acceleration magnetic
field I get all the other kind of Mecca
dresses I see so I can tell you from
that with whom you speak and whom you
see because their phones will send you
these addresses and I can say also based
on that where you are and what you're
doing in signal States and everything's
it's an awful lot of information one of
the critical things here is ethics
because if somebody comes to my house
and I've got all this stuff on I can
tell you so many things about them that
I'm not supposed to know and it's really
bad if you invite someone for dinner and
he said by the way you've got a hard
problem go to your doctor so ethics
don't always like that particularly much
so time is running very far
and I'm probably not gonna get through
everything I wanted to say let's make
this year a bit smaller again so the
interesting bit is that we can combine
all this data which is measured in
different time scales different sampling
rates into one single system with the
Wolfram language because it's so
flexible about how you store data that's
a very powerful thing so here we've got
a EEG data and we've got movement data
from the X Box now what happens is that
usually we implant the electrodes but
sometimes well just to show that this
can be done differently
we actually have you an extra cranial
EEG and we have X Box date and other
thing is when your muscles move when you
move like that you get huge spikes in
your EEG signal because the muscles
produce electric segments and that makes
the signal basically useless because you
see a second here this is nice going up
and down that's my 50 Hertz that's just
the electricity here I move a little bit
and you get out of control you don't
actually get any kind of useful signal
and what you would usually do and the
code is all in here so you can see how
this works
you would get an odd feature for example
you filter out the 50 Hertz frequencies
and other things and you get something
like that there you see at the beginning
looks like that but you still you have
these very very large artifacts now
beyond is a magician in terms of data
analysis so we will use state space
modeling to actually get rid of these
artifacts to clean up your data so this
is the cleaned up data based on a little
bit of code the code that will be in the
workbook that you can download in a
notebook will not be the complete one
did not run in real-time it'll take
about five minutes for for a ten-second
signal or something like that with
hiddenville from language without
anything else we managed to get it in in
faster than real time and I think that's
the first time that that algorithm and
it's um similar algorithm could be done
in real time on all the electrodes in an
EEG and lots of other movements there
now this thing learns from the movement
data because it's got the Xbox data that
I'm moving here and that allows the
program to know these are artifacts
filter them away in case it's a very
powerful kind of analysis too and that's
just one of the hundreds of examples
that we need to make the signal nice and
clean and usable because these data
points are not really always very good
now
is just a simple example that's the
naive Kalman filter it's slightly
different than the Kalman filter that's
implemented in the Wolfram language so
what I do is I generate a signal and add
noise to it and spikes so basically I
then run it through this filter and what
we get is kind of like this so the time
series with noise is the blue one you've
got these large spikes the Kalman filter
is the orange one and the green one is
the original one so it basically it this
is an e very easy case because it
filters the way just the spikes but even
if there is observational noise or other
types of noise it just filters them out
additionally and use all these other
data sets like movement data heart rate
data everything aids blinking data
whether you blink and I can use a
combination of that and this program
will basically take these things apart
use the information and filter out what
you have to do now they're just a couple
of seconds left so let me just show how
this at the end works so this is a
spectrogram of the original data you see
the 50 Hertz and you see lots of
artifacts this is an odd filter it gets
rid of the 50 Hertz kind of line but it
basically makes a bump there so you
filter out too much and if I look at the
estimated spectrum this is how it looks
now what that means is that I can now
use for example movement data and brain
data this year would be artificial
spikes in the data that I can't use and
it would filter the brain nice and clean
so that even from external electrodes
you get a very very clean signal that
you can actually use for example to work
on epileptic seizures and things we can
do networks and stuff like that is one
last thing I just mentioned because I'm
over time and that's can of course use
machine learning for example to detect
automatically different patterns for
example you same person is standing
brain activity as such and such person
is sitting brain activity such-and-such
and it gets these kind of different
states out automatically basically so I
don't have to really go by hand through
all the data and say what does
mean but I can classify it into
different categories and can basically
tell you exactly what the person is
doing at home and here this for example
is a completely artificial I mean an
artifact destroyed kind of system
I can ask it's very easy because all
built into the language of course I can
make little questionnaires and I can ask
the patients or people who use the
system for for input so it's a little
questionnaire like that I can ask any
questions
this is collected in a database I can
analyze the data plane levels and I can
ask for that and I can interrupt this so
if people get an epileptic seizures like
I can I can just before write them it'll
take some I should say look at your
phone play this game do something else
perhaps that helps to prevent the
seizure because you actually do
something really different and last but
not least there is a little thing we
also wrote that's feedback to the user
so basically we use pushbullet which is
also in Mathematica directly to have an
automated system that can send this type
of information to the user so we can say
look something is coming up in your
brainwaves
do something else take a pill do this do
that and of course there's a complete
protocol of everything that's happened
the doctors can be informed immediately
patient family members can be informed
and so on and so on so these are cases
where we use lots of data combined it's
just a tiny tiny fraction of all the
data we use we use data about your
driving style a little device that plugs
into your car and we see how your cell
rate are you aggressive when you drive
or not so I think we can do
approximately 100 150 different sensors
at the moment and that of course
produces an awful lot of data that we
have to analyze thank you very much
you